how are you this morning burnin I'm good
how are you now did I sum that up
correctly that you're saying look I'm
every bit the equal that these other
quarterbacks are in this draft yes sir
you did all right why is it you're not
getting any love for many of these teams
I think is because I'm shorter so I'm
sorry I'm the shortest quarterback in
the draft you know so I think like like
you said I think if I was 63 I think
none of this would be even a problem to
be honest are you better than Jared gone
honestly myself I think you know if I'm
not as good as him then I am better than
him you know I'm not going to say here
to say he's he's better than because
there's nothing that he's doing that I
can't do like you know so yeah are you
better than Carson wins I said he's the
only quarterback in this draft that I
can literally say he's he's better than
me I've seen him at the combine he made
every single throw I've been watching
him since you know we were both freshmen
he's legit he's a legit quarterback I
give me your official height 510 in
three fourths or some so you're you're
the exact height as Russell Wilson yes
sir okay what do these teams say what
why is it you can't do what you do in
college you won't be able to do that in
the NFL because you're three or four
inches shorter than some of these other
guys um I mean I don't know you know
that's just what I so people say that's
what people like you say that's what a
you know so everybody say but until you
know I get out there on the field you
know not sure what i could do then you
notice a difference you know oh I don't
buy into that you got to be 64 here
Vernon I I don't bind any of that
nonsense I think they're guys that can
play you know if I looked at russell
wilson or drew brees they said why you
guys aren't tall enough how stupid would
I sound I I think they're guys who can
play the position
I think they're guys who look like they
can play the position there's a big
difference in that and I do think these
Scouts get caught up in you got to be 64
65 to withstand the punishment or be
able to see over the line of scrimmage
so no I don't don't include me in that
mm-hmm okay yeah i mean if you can play
you can play and you know it definitely
and I can play so and if you ain't if
you don't think I can play you don't
think i'm not i'm not gonna say I'm
gonna get drafted you know because you
know I've heard anything from you know
late fourth or whatever to undrafted and
that's fine to be honest I really you
know I just let a game of football
that's all I just want to play football
I'm tired like you know seeing
everything I just want to be out there
again you know and whether i'm free
agent whatever we come in i prepare
harder than anybody you know on the team
so i'm gonna come in that's all that
matters no stop it's not about your
height is about your football IQ and how
much you prepare for the game it's like
I went up to the to the pac-12 from no
eastern Washington you know at first it
was little rocky I broke my finger I
played in about 22 games my finger
broken on my throwing hand so that's why
I wasn't producing at first but my
finger was healthy from you university
of washington are all the way to tcu you
see a huge difference in my plate you
see a huge difference and everything and
that's what I'm trying to pitch I'm not
a cocky dude at all you know I'm saying
I'm very humble but just to tell
everybody just put on the film when I'm
not playing and put on the film when I
am playing going back to eastern
Washington going back to Oregon whatever
you want to go back to I'm just going to
tell you I'm a game changer you know so
whenever I get that shot whoever I'm
backing up next year or whatever I'm
gonna be the best backup and when i get
my shot go out there and have fun that's
what I do best I go out there have fun
i'll make plays I love it I love it if
we're in the huddle right now I'm
killing for you as you should yeah all
right I'll throw my body out there I'll
block for you whatever it takes here now
did you talk to former Oregon coach Chip
Kelly did you visit the Niners I didn't
visit them but I did talk to him out in
at the combine and how that go me it was
good you know is everybody talks
everybody on the camera you know this
it's nothing special it's not like you
know nothing special at all you know he
talked to I'm sure he talked to you he
talked all the other quarterback so you
know there's nothing nothing special do
you try to make yourself taller what do
you mean to touch how to make myself
taller did you put lifts in your shoes
or I'm not worried telling of that it's
put on the film I don't need to make
myself I'm not going to get any taller
no is watch the film we're talking to
burnin Adams former Oregon quarterback
joining a stand Patrick show where will
you be during the draft my grandparents
house in the Los Angeles just gonna have
you know just my family there and no not
no party nothing just my media family
just all together and like I said
whether I get drafted and I it's a
celebration of my college career you
know or you want to watch the draft I'm
not not probably not the first two days
I'm not because i'm pretty sure i might
get picked up those who day so maybe I
think Saturday that third day I'll
probably sit down him know watch it a
little bit and hope my phone rings well
I'm rooting for you you know what it's
the kind of attitude you have to take to
the NFL as you want to be great Russell
Wilson had it people didn't believe it
and he said look this is who I really am
I love the game I want to be great and
they finally got a chance so hopefully
you get that chance that's all you're
asking for Vernon we we appreciate you
joining us yes sir thank you guys for
having me all right at seven and Adams
Oregon quarterback the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience